♪ ♪
>> Greg: I KNOW I HAVE A HOLE
IN MY SWEATER.
I SHOULD NOT HAVE RAISED MY
HAND.
I RAISED MY HAND.
YOU KNOW IT'S FROM?
IT'S FROM WORKING OUT.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED?
I WAS IN THE GREEN ROOM AND I
SAID THIS IS GREG'S SWEATER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, SO DID THE
PRINCE KILL JAMAL KHASHOGGI?
MAYBE HE DID.
MAYBE HE DIDN'T.
THAT IS FROM TRUMP, CAUSING
DELAYS HAIR BURNING MEDIA FREAK
OUT WHICH HAPPENS WHENEVER TRUMP
TELLS THE TRUTH ABOUT A POLICY
WE WERE OKAY WITH WELL BEFORE
HIM.
SO NOW YOU ARE PISSED OFF AT THE
SAUDIS?
THIS IS WHAT GETS YOUR GOAT?
ACCORDING TO BEN RHODES WHEN
OBAMA WENT TO RIYADH, THE SAUDI
KING GAVE EACH STAFFER A PILE OF
JEWELS IN THE FIRST COUPLE GOT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND POUNDS WORTH OF
BUBBLES WHICH WERE ACCEPTED AND
SENT THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
THAT BEATS A WASHER AND DRYER ON
PRICE IS RIGHT.
EVEN BACK THEN WE KNEW THAT
SAUDI ARABIA, THEY WERE
DIFFERENT BUT THEY WERE ALLIES
AND ALLIES CAN SUCK.
MAY BE THE BOSSES HAD JAMAL
KHASHOGGI OFT.
IF YOU SAY THE PRINT IS GUILTY,
YOU ARE COMMITTING POKER SUICIDE
BY FOLDING WHILE HOLDING OUT THE
BEST CARDS.
SHORT OF APPLYING YOUR MORAL ACE
MIGHT PLEASE EVERYONE IN THE
MEDIA BUT WINNING THEIR APPROVAL
WINS AMERICAN NOTHING.
IT'S A WASTE OF GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
HOLD OFF AND SAY MAYBE, MAYBE
NOT.
MAYBE NOT, YOU COME OUT AHEAD IN
THE POT YOU WANT TO END IMPACT
YOUR COUNTRY'S HAPPINESS.
IF YOU SPENT YOUR LIFE PLAYING
THIS GAME, KEEPING YOUR CARDS
CLOSE AND WAITING, YOU KNOW
AMERICA HAS THE SAUDIS OVER A
BARREL.
MILLIONS OF BARRELS, REALLY.
IN NEGOTIATIONS IT MEANS YOU CAN
GET SOMETHING BACK FROM THEM
THAT YOU COULDN'T HAVE BEFORE.
LIKE WHAT?
MIDDLE EAST PROGRESS, CHANCE FOR
PEACE IN PALESTINE AND ISRAEL.
THE ABILITY TO INFLUENCE WHAT
OIL PRICES.
WHO KNOWS?
FOR SURE IT WILL BE MORE THAN A
PILE OF DUMB JEWELS.
DANA, THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
WHAT I SAY WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IF THE SAUDIS DON'T OFFER
AMERICA SOMETHING REALLY BIG,
THEN YOU CAN GO BACK IN SIX
MONTHS AND SAY THEY KILLED THAT
GUY.
>> Dana: MAYBE YOU ARE RIGHT.
MAYBE YOU ARE NOT.
EXCLAMATION POINT.
FRIENDS CAN SOMETIMES MAKE IT
REALLY HARD TO DEFEND THEM.
I KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
BUT IT'S OBVIOUSLY A COMPLEX
SITUATION.
THE END RESULT WAS MAYBE ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THIS.
COMMUNICATIONS IS IMPORTANT.
MAYBE HE IS SPEAKING TO A
CERTAIN AUDIENCE.
SPEAKING TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
AUDIENCE AT ONCE.
THE TWEET TODAY WHERE HE SAYS
"OIL PRICES GETTING LOWER."
HE SAYING SAUDI ARABIA FOR THAT.
OVER A BARREL?
THEY BE THE SHOE'S ON THE OTHER
FOOT.
MAKING THE TOUGH DECISION TO GET
OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL WOULD'VE
BEEN THE WRONG ONE IF OIL PRICES
ARE THE REAL ATTENTION.
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
BECAUSE IT'S COMPLEX.
IT DOESN'T SAY IT IN THE TWEETS,
THAT'S A TOUGH THING.
HUMAN RIGHTS IS IN OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY'S INTEREST.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
DIFFICULT.
I ALSO FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT
COULD HAVE GOTTEN MORE OUT OF
IT.
YOU ARE SAYING WE SHOULD GET
SOMETHING OUT OF IT BUT WHY
WOULD WE GET ANYTHING NOW WHEN
HE'S ALREADY SAID EVERYTHING IS
COOL.
MAYBE BEHIND THE SCENES.
WOULDN'T IT HAVE BEEN GREAT IF
WE HAD FOUND OUT TODAY THAT
SAUDI HAD RELEASED ALL THE WOMEN
THEY PUT IN DETENTION BECAUSE
THEY HAD THE TEMERITY TO GET OUT
THERE AND DRIVE BEFORE THEIR
REGULATIONS WERE ALLOWED OR
MAYBE ALL THESE OTHER THINGS WE
COULD'VE ASKED FOR THEM TO DO
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS STANDPOINT.
>> Greg: I THINK OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY INTERESTS ARE OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS.
THAT'S THE HARD REALITY.
THINK WHAT WE ARE GOING FOR IT
IS SOMETHING IN THE MIDDLE EAST
THAT IS BIGGER THAN OIL.
>> Juan: DIDN'T HE SAY THE
SAME THING ABOUT RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
GOING TO BE A HELPFUL ALLY.
>> Greg: I WOULD USE
NORTH KOREA AS AN EXAMPLE.
>> Juan: THE FACT IS IT'S NOT
ABOUT OUR NATIONAL INTERESTS TO
HAVE OUR MORALS, OUR PRINCIPLES.
>> Greg: YOU ARE LOOKING AT
THE TINIEST PART OF THIS.
>> Juan: WE ARE SAYING TO
PEOPLE MORE DICTATORS AND WHO
ARE MURDERERS YOU CAN DO
BUSINESS WITH US.
IT'S ALL TRANSACTIONAL.
AS LONG AS YOU PROMISE US MORE
JOBS AND MORE OIL.
WAIT A SECOND.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
HE SAYS IT'S $350 BILLION, TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
EVERY FACT-CHECKER IN AMERICA
SAYS THAT'S NOT TRUE.
SO THE TRANSACTION IS ONE-SIDED.
WE ARE SAYING TO THEM YOU KNOW
WHAT, GO RIGHT AHEAD.
TO ME, THAT'S -- IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE, GREG.
>> Greg: HERE'S HOW I LOOK AT
IT.
HE TOOK THE HARD WAY OUT.
HE COULD OF VIRTUE SIGNALED AND
MADE ALL OF YOU GUYS HAPPY BUT
HE DIDN'T APPEAR HE DOESN'T NEED
TO SATISFY A MORNING BLOW.
INSTEAD HE EMBRACES THE ROLE OF
THE COLD HARD PARENT WHO IS
RIGHT.
IF YOU JUST FOCUS ON THIS ONE
INCIDENT AND BLOW THE FUTURE,
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Steve: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON,
A LOT OF LAWMAKERS ARE SAYING WE
WANT SANCTIONS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID.
>> Dana: SANCTIONS ON 12
PEOPLE WHO ARE SLATED TO BE
KILLED.
WHAT DO THIS SANCTIONS MATTER?
>> Steve: THE PRESIDENT SAYS
YOU WANT SANCTIONS, CONGRESS,
THEN PASSED SANCTIONS.
I HEARD RUSH LIMBAUGH ON THE
RADIO YESTERDAY SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT PEOPLE IN EUROPE ARE
SAYING WELL, WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO DO?
WE ARE WAITING ON HIM TO DO
SOMETHING.
WHY DOESN'T EUROPE DO SOMETHING?
>> Dana: THEY DID.
GERMANY TODAY ENDED THEIR ARMS
SALES.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST EITHER.
A COUNTRY THAT YOU NEED IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND NOT BUY YOUR
WEAPONS.
YOU WANT THEM TO BUY YOUR
>> Steve: WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT GOING TO DO?
I THINK HE'S DOING IT.
HE'S A BUSINESSMAN.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU HEARD
BUSINESSMEN SAVES NOTHING
PERSONAL.
IT'S JUST BUSINESS.
IN THIS CASE IT'S AMERICA'S
BUSINESS.
>> Jedidiah: I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT HE LOOKED AT IT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A BUSINESSMAN.
I THINK HE COULD HAVE DONE THAT
MADE THE STATEMENT BETTER.
HAD HE DONE THE VERY SAME THING
THAT HE DID SO WITHIN THAT
STATEMENT A BIT HARDER WHEN IT
CAME TO THE MURDER OF A
JOURNALIST, BE LESS TOLERANT OF
THAT.
THERE WERE ANGLES OF THE
STATEMENT MARK HAMILL SEEMED
LIKE HE WAS TAKING THE SAUDI
CROWN PRINCE'S VERSION OF THE
STORY OVER THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
IF HE WANTS TO MAINTAIN THAT
THIS IS THE STRATEGIC ALLY AND
HE WANTS TO COME AT IT FROM THE
ANGLE OF A BUSINESSMAN, I THINK
THAT'S OKAY TO EXTEND BUT YOU
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF THE WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE LOOKING AT THIS
THAT WANT THE MESSAGE SENT THAT
IF A REGIME VIOLATES HUMAN
RIGHTS EXTENSIVELY THEY EXPECT
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT AMERICAN
PRESIDENT TO HAVE A REACTION TO
THAT THAT IS SUBSTANTIAL AND
MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE HE CARES
ABOUT OUR ECONOMIC INTERESTS BUT
HE ALSO CARES ABOUT THE VALUE OF
THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO AGREES
WITH YOU?
TRICKY.
I AM HAPPY TO SEE TURKEY COME
OUT AGAINST HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
AND COME AT US FOR THAT.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT JUST TURKEY.
WHAT STRIKES ME IS THE NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS.
NORMALLY WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
BEING AS POPULAR AS HE IS AMONG
REPUBLICANS, YOU DON'T SEE THE
SENATE AND CONGRESS STEP UP TO
HIM.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS MARCO
RUBIO, RAND PAUL, LINDSEY
GRAHAM, BOB CORKER, JEFF FLAKE,
THESE GUYS WERE SAYING THIS IS
WRONG.